means it's time for friday follies you
know it
for that we turn to author the
forthcoming book the thief who stole
heaven fox news contributor raymond
arroyo
all right raimondo biden had a very very
big town hall i know you watched it the
other night and
there were a few answers that were
troubling
yeah i'll say and they got very little
coverage laura
joe biden has a history as you know of
saying racially insensitive things and
that tradition
continued at the town hall with no
objection from anderson cooper
did you ever five years ago think every
second or third ad out of five or six
you turn on would be bi-racial couples
not everybody in the community in the
hispanic and the african-american
community
particularly in rural areas that are
distant
and or inner city districts know how to
use
know how to get online so so wait a
minute laura
are only lilly white people uh that they
have no
technical challenges if they're lilly
white it's only we hispanics
and the african-americans who have
difficulty getting online this is the
man
you'll remember during the campaign
laura who said
go to joe 33033 oh he didn't know the
text and it was text 3303
when you want to bring the country
together it's best not to lead
with racial divisiveness and racial
identity
in the forefront it's a bad look and
doesn't have anything better to do
than to catalog the the color-coded
nature of various
commercials i mean they used to say well
trump just watches tv apparently biden's
the one watching tv and making a note of
how many
uh racial and bi-racial couples that's
just i found that odd
i agree the racial stereotyping is not a
good look on him and the president
offered one admission lawyer that was
quite
startling and i'm sure he knows where he
is
i get up in the morning look at jill and
say where the hell are we i didn't
realize
i had been in the oval office a hundred
times as vice president or
more than that um every morning uh for
the
initial meetings but i had never been
up in the residence he had never been up
to the private residence laura you and i
have been up to the private rest
so much for that obama biden bromance
story we keep hearing so much remember
that narrative
aside from ceremonial uh duties and veep
episodes
these two apparently weren't all that
close but that didn't stop
former obama campaign manager jim
messina
from getting emotional i teared up at
that
it was amazing to see scranton joe kind
of be honest about
saying wow this is my life
i teared up for a different reason
thinking this man is actually
running our country i did tear up as
well